[Musique]
incubaliance c'est l'Incubateur
Technologique mutualisé du Campus Paris
saclé c'est en terme de de volume de
projet et en terme d'ancien projets
transformé en société en entreprise le
premier incubateur technologique de
France il a déjà quinzaine années
d'existence et globalement plus de 260
projets sont passés par l'incubateur et
ils ont donné lieu à environ 160
entreprises qui sont vivantes et actives
dans notre écosystème et au-delà en
France et à
l'étranger notre métier consiste donc à
accompagner les projets avant la
création des start-ups jusqu'à leur
démarrage commercial après que bien sûr
la société a été créée après que le
business model la stratégie de la
start-up a été travaillée et retravaillé
avec nous pendant de longues séances de
travail après que l'équipe a été
renforcée après que le produit a été
commercialisé bref toutes ces activités
concernent l'incubation et nous y
contribuons nous aidons l'entrepreneur à
faire en sorte qu'il sorte par le E vers
une trajectoire prometteuse à la sortie
de de
l'incubateur nous sommes un incubateur
généraliste donc nous avons des projets
de start-up qui couvrent tous les
domaines technologiques nous avons des
projets qui concernent les sciences de
la vie et les biotches nous travaillons
avec notre écosystème notamment
genénopole Cancer Campus nous avons
beaucoup de projets qui concernent les
technologies traditionnelles de
l'ingénieur notamment l'optique et nous
travaillons notamment avec l'écosystème
d'optique comme auquel appartient optics
Valley et l'OGS l'école d'optique et
nous travaillons bien sûr sur tous les
projets
titic incontournable surtout à Paris
Sacla incub alliance est constitutif du
territoire ça a été la première
plateforme mutualisée du plateau de sa
clé les membres d'incube alliance sont
tous les établissements de recherche et
de développement et d'enseignement
supérieur du plateau de sa clé dans les
gèes même de l'entreprise se trouve la
recherche et le développement et
notamment ce qu'on appelle le
rapprochement ou l'adossement des
projets au laboratoire de recherche et
développement du plateau de sa
clé